what is a welcome back to another Unreal
Engine course and this time we have a
really cool let's just see the game that
you are going to create so if I hit the
play button we have a nice ball we have
a nice glowy effect we can move the ball
left and right we can jump with the ball
so this laser over here is gonna kill us
pay attention at the top left corner for
our energy BAM is being drained as you
can see we can interact with these cubes
I can you know like push it or drag it
towards me like this and I can jump from
one wall to another like spider-man over
here and of course you're going to learn
how to do all of this we do need to drag
this other cube so that we can prevent
these other lasers from killing us and
there you go now we can jump on the
elevator click on the e button to
interact and when we jump off the
elevator it goes down and no now we
cannot reach the tab what we can do well
we can jump and interact with this cube
there you go so you can do that as well
damn there you go and we can jump over
here and voila we reach the top of
course this project you will have
assignments in it that's the beauty of
it so I will give you assignments to
finish the game and you can add new
features because this serves like a
template that you can use to build upon
so you can add new features and that's
way you can learn and so on and so forth
now even though this looks like a some
simple game believe me you're gonna
learn a lot of cool things because a lot
of interesting things went into creating
this project so again just go through it
you will have assignments to finish it
because I will show you how you can
rearrange these rocks to create other
levels to add new features more
obstacles so on and so forth again well
while my channel is still not dying and
I'm not asking for help just you know
share the video like it subscribe and
comment below it helps the algorithm so
this channel can grow so yeah we were
all a community over here so be part of
a community like share it so I mean
other people can benefit and you helped
me as well so it's a win-win situation
anyways thank you I guess thank you for
watching this video and stay out of jail
I guess man because you know you cannot
watch this video if you if you're in
jail take care and enjoy the rest of the
tutorial so now that we saw the game
you're going to create let us actually
create the game so over here I have the
Unreal Engine project browser you know
what it is so we're going to click here
on the games and then click on next over
here we want a blank project from here
click on next
blueprint is fine we don't need the
starter content so you can either do it
with or without but you know essentially
we don't need it everything over here
can be as is now over here as you
already know is where you're going to
store the project so make sure that you
well set that to your desired location
and over here is the name of your
project so we are going to call it Platt
for mur there you go and I'm going to
click on create the project and voila we
are going to wait probably a gazillion
years and I think I think that I will
need to cut out the video so uh yeah see
you when this finishes and the finally
we are here it didn't take that long but
I still had to cut it out because you
will probably be mad to be like oh and
I'm not gonna go further into the head
just kidding but anyways the next step
for us is to click here on the content
right click that is in show in Explorer
there you go so this is where we are
going to put the assets and the assets
are right here so these are the assets
you can download them link will be below
this video so just you know scroll down
below the video and you will see a link
where you can download the assets and
what you're going to do is copy all of
these so copy all of the assets
everything that you see in this asset
folder and over here again right click
here on the content show in Explorer and
it will open this bad boy for you right
click and paste the assets so when you
paste the assets we are good to go now
when we go here in the maps and click on
the example map voila this is our map
now again these are all you see as you
can see separate items that you can put
together in order to create the level
and what I'm also going to do is here
inside of the outliner so world outliner
which is on the right I am going to
right click over here and create a
folder and is going to be level parts or
how everyone going to call them and I'm
going to select all these rocks and I am
going to put them inside of the level
parts folder just so that we can
organize them a little bit and we don't
have you know everything clustered
inside of this inside of the world
outliner anyways what's good about this
is that you can always you know you can
move these things around to create new
levels yada-yada-yada it's service like
a template and stuff like that so you
know for the assignments that I will
give you later on to create new levels
you can do that on your own so basically
that's that anyways the next step for us
is to go and create our ball player so
let's go over here in the blueprints
which is currently empty I'm going to
right click and we are going to create a
blueprint class and this class is going
to inherit from the character now as you
can see here characters are pawns and
have a match blah blah blah blah click
on that and this is going to be BP
underscore player ball so player
underscore ball or you can put that
everything you can put that all together
it's up to you you know it's not
important and I don't care you know I
don't care what you do okay it's your
life you can do whatever you want but
anyways just kidding what you need to do
or what we are going to do now is that
we are going to add a mesh and all the
good stuff now first things first we are
going to attach or add a static or
actually yeah a static mesh component so
let's go in here click on add component
to filter first static mesh component
here it is this is the bad boy as you
can see this is the skeletal mesh we
don't want that we want this one static
mesh component now for the static mesh
click here as you can see where it says
the static mesh click there and filter
for the ball
so click ball and SM ball here it is so
click on that one and there you go this
is our ball it's you know very funny now
over here for the elements we are going
to search for the ball element so click
here ball or filter for the ball and
there you go it looks like a golf ball
you know it looks like a golf ball so
we're
to say it's a golf ball anyways what we
are also going to do is we are going to
scale it so over here in the transform
for the scale click on the lock icon and
we are going to say 1.5 for the scale to
rescale the ball so it gets a little bit
you know larger also for our capsule
component what we are going to do over
here is the half height and the radius
are going to be 75 for the half height
radius is going to be also 75 so as you
can see now the whole ball is covered in
the radius of the capsule component make
sure that you compile and say that what
I am also going to do is I'm going to
attach a spring arm so click here an add
component and filter for the spring arm
now if you don't know what is a spring
are basically it's a holder for the
camera so you can think of a spring arm
as a holder for the camera what we are
going to do for the spring arm is over
here for the rotation and the z-axis we
are going to say negative 90 there you
go and we are also going to set the
target arm length so this over here in
the camera it's currently at 300 we're
going to set it at 1 5 3 6 so 1536
which is going to make that a little bit
further away from the ball there you go
when it comes to the target offset for
the z-axis we are going to set that at
300 there you go and basically as you
can see it's right over here like in a
diagonal way with an angle it's looking
at that ball so basically that's that do
collision test over here we don't need
this so if true do a collision test
using probe channel probe size you you
know we don't need this we don't need
this so compile and save that and the
next step for us is selecting the spring
arm and attaching the camera so click on
the camera and there you go so now we
have the camera on it when it comes to
the camera we are basically not going to
touch anything we don't need to touch
anything because we have everything set
within the within the spring arm now
make sure that you compile and save that
if I were to go over here in the example
map and hit on play button and over here
just one second we do you have because I
prepared this project and some of the
things that we do need to delete what we
need to do is go here while you're in
the example map level click on the you
see over here where it says blueprints
click on the drop-down list and click
here open level brew blueprint when you
click on that just delete these two
notes so just the leave these two you
compile and save that this is later on
for creating the UI for the game so when
we have our UI we will have this over
here or or somewhere else it's not
important but that is for the UI if I
hit the play button now everything is
cool but you see this over here we don't
have our ball we don't have anything so
what we need to do is go back here in
the content browser inside of the
blueprints and right click and create a
blueprint class and from here from all
classes in the search we are going to
filter for game mode and we want this
one game mode so make sure that you
select the game mode click on select and
is going to be BP underscore Platt
former underscore game mode so this is
our platformer game mode we only need it
for one reason and that is to go inside
of the project settings and click your
maps and modes and over here at the tab
where it says default game mode we're
not going to set the game mode base
instead we are going to say the
platformer game of the one that we have
just created which now enables us to
edit the default pawn class which is
actually the player so from the default
pawn class we're going to select the BP
player ball which means now when we go
here in our example map let me just
close the example mat blueprint
over here as you can see I have already
prepared from this level this is the
player start or where the player is
going to be spawn when we in run our
game so if I hit play now there you go
we have the ball and this is because we
created the game mode base and we
attached it over here and we set the
player ball to be the default pawn class
and now when we you know
the game ideas being spawned moving
forward let us go back inside of our
player ball and what we are going to do
first is create the variables that we
need so the first variable is going to
be our ball material instance like this
now I am going to just declare all of
these then I'm going to set the types
and whatnot next we have the move
direction next we are going to have over
here flat velocity and what did I type
over here so it's flat velocity there
you go click on the plus and again here
we have the current speed moving forward
we have the rotation amounts of rotation
amount moving forward we have the ball
rotation rate moving forward we have the
power we have the energies energy and is
dead here's that and last but not least
we are going to have the HUD reference
so click here compile and save and what
we are going to do well first things
first we are going to set the ball
material instance click on you can
either click here so you can either
click here on this like on the red one
because currently all of these variables
are boolean and you can either click
there where I'm currently pointing with
this arrow or you can click on here
variable type which is in the details
tab on the right side and from there you
can click here on the search and you're
going to search for material and you
want a dynamic material instance let me
just find it over here actually is it
dynamic or just material let me just see
over here so it's dynamic material yeah
here it is material instance dynamic
this is what we want and you're going to
click on this object reference this is
what we need so material instance
dynamic move direction is going to be a
vector so click on the button to choose
a variable type and move direction is
going to be a vector flat velocity is
also going to be a vector so click on
the button to change the type
the variable the current speed is going
to be afloat so click on the button and
select float the rotation amount same is
going to be afloat so click on there the
ball rotation rate is also going to be
afloat but for the ball rotation rate we
are going to set the default value so
the default value for the ball rotation
rate is going to be point 75 and you can
set the value over here where I have
just drawn now moving forward we are
going to have our power and energy both
of these are going to be floats so float
here energies also flow to make sure
that you compile and save that and over
here the value for these both are going
to be 100 so 100 for the energy 100 for
the power is that is going to be a
boolean and we're going to leave it as
is here for the energy and power make
them publicly available and also for our
also for our puzzle mode so we have one
more variable which is going to be our
puzzle mode and I am going to move it
over here and put it right directly
below the material instance so I just
change the order even though the order
doesn't matter but hey so here I'm going
to say puzzle mode there you go click on
the button over here and we are going to
set this to be a boolean compile and
save this bad boy and also the puzzle
mode just set it over here to be a
public one now this is for the variables
that we are going to use moving forward
what we are going to do we are going to
first create our event so I can remove
this from here we will need this later
on but over here right click and for the
node we are going to search for a custom
event custom event is the one that we
created it's not already defined we are
going to define it right now
so I'm going to call this bad boy enable
this able input and this is going to
allow us to either enable and disable
the input now one thing when you click
on this over here you can have these
inputs which are basically parameters so
I can click on over here for the plus
button and add a new parameter and over
here the parameter is going to be a
bully
and the name is going to be enable so
there you go and now we have a boolean
parameter over here so what's gonna
happen here is that we are going to go
in a branch and the branch is an if-else
statement and the condition that we are
going to test is this enable so enable
is the condition that we are going to
test it's either true or false if it's
true we are going to enable the input
but before that we are going to get the
player controller because the player
controller is the one who can enable and
disable the input so over here I can say
enable input like this and right click
over here I can say this able input now
this is going to enable and disable the
input on the player controller which
means it will disable the input on our
ball there you go
so if it's true we are going to enable
the input and I'm going to click on this
and I'm going to position like this and
if it's false we are going to disable
the input because the parameter is
enabled if enable is true then we're
going to enable the input if it's false
we are going to disable the input pretty
straightforward here I'm going to create
a comment section I'm going to call this
bad boy enable backslash this abel input
and if you didn't see how I created a
comment section basically what you need
to do is just you know hover or or
select with your mouse like this by
dragging your left mouse select all the
nodes that you want to group in a
comment then right click and go over
here create comment from section and of
course you can select this comment you
can delete it and it can go away so if I
select it now and hit delete it will be
deleted and go away over here everything
is straight forward I don't think there
is no extra explanation for this or if
there is just you know let me know in
the comment below the video anyways
moving forward we want another we want
another custom event so let's go over
here and right click and we are going to
filter for custom event and we're going
to add here a custom event then we are
going to call this one change ball
material instance so the name of this
bad boy is going to be just double-click
it over here again
ok here it is change ball material in
there you go now this actually excuse me
it's change ball material color not
instance color so change ball material
color now this bad boy has two
parameters click on him and inputs click
plus two times the first one is going to
be the parameter M name and the type
over here is actually going to be the
name so name is going to be the
parameter and over here we are going to
have a value float so here we're going
to say value and there you go so compile
and save that again as you can see we
have two parameters one is the name and
other is the value what we are going to
do is we are going to get the ball
material instance so we are going to get
it which is the one over here that we
have as you can see here is the bad boy
what we are going to do now we are going
to drag from here a node and we're going
to say set scalar parameter basically
this is going to change the value of the
parameters over here we're going to plug
this in so this goes over here next
we're going to plug in the parameter
name over here and the value will be
plugged over here and after that we are
going to get the ball mesh so here we
have the static mesh and I need to
change the name to the ball mesh I mean
it's not important but you know for our
references it is better to know so this
is a ball mesh and we are going to say
over here set material there you go not
this so from here set material and we
want this one
so set material there you go plug this
in over here this goes over here and
last but not least we want the material
which is the ball material instance so
here
get the ball material instance and plug
it in and there you go compile and save
that now what I'm going to do is select
this and again right click and create a
comment from section there's going to be
change ball material color and make sure
that you can Paulo save this what is
this essentially what is this going to
do well basically if I go over here and
select the ball material and you see
here we have the ball material if I
click on it
is that material and let me just open it
so over here is the material now I'm not
going to go into this because this is a
separate topic on its own you know
dragging these materials creating them
with the nodes and whatnot
but over here we have some parameters
like power like is active and so on and
so forth that control certain aspects of
that material as you can see we then
have the divide and put it in the lerp
and multiply and basically as I said
this is a separate topic on its own I
will probably create a separate video
just talking about how to create
materials how to do this and that with
them but essentially what you need to
know for this tutorial is that these
parameters like power is active and so
on and so forth
they control the colors of this material
so over here now when we call this
change ball material color the parameter
value is going to be one of these
parameters such as power such as is
active so we're going to put that in the
name over here and the value is going to
be well basically value one two three it
doesn't matter you know but the value of
the number now what we need to do in
order for to make this work is go over
here in the begin play and I'm going to
move a little bit up over here the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
get the material of the ore from the
ball so here from the event begin play
we're going to drag a node that we're
going to call set ball material instance
don't actually excuse me first we need
to create that so let me just get the
ball mesh first get the ball mesh and
from here get the material so get the
ball mesh first and then get the ball
material from the mesh and from the mesh
we are going to create dynamic material
instance there you go and we're going to
plug this in over here actually let me
just do it like this create dynamic
material instance there you go and the
target is going to be capsule match ball
mesh now just take a look at this what
is this over here
it's not giving me the target is
primitive component kismat library let
me just go over here create dynamic
material we want the one from the well
all of these are from kismet no we want
the first one create dynamic material
instance this is the one that we want so
you can get confused sometimes with
these because as you can see create
dynamic material instance you see we
have you know a couple of these
functions so we want the first one
create dynamic material instance and we
want to plug in the parent over here and
it goes right there so the next part
then we can move this closer because I'm
going to create a comment from this the
next part is to set the ball material
instance there you go and we want to set
it to this return value that we have
over here see returns value material
instance dynamic object reference so we
can set that to this over here now I'm
going to select these and I'm going to
right click and create a comment section
and what's gonna happen here first I'm
going to say first set the material
instance material in stands there you go
and we can move this from here so you
can move the begin play a little bit
outside it's not important but you know
just you know just so-so
something like this there you go maybe a
little bit up because later on we are
going to plug things here in the tick
event so we got the material instance
what is the next step the next step over
here is to first enable disable hampel
so we are going to say enable this able
input and over here we have the
parameter we're going to leave at false
as you can see or no already if it's
false we are going to disable the input
so we're not going to allow the
character to move so disable the input
after that we're going to say change
ball material color the parameter name
that you are going to pass is going to
be is active and notice here is active
capital i capital a the value over here
or the name that we pass over here as
the parameter needs to match up with the
name of
here as you can see this is the name of
that is active so is active you can
click on it and you can copy the name
and you can then go back over here and
paste it just to be sure like that the
value is going to be zero so we're going
to leave the value at zero and now we
are going to delay so we're going to
call the layover here and we are going
to delay for 0.5 seconds so half a
second we are going to delay and after
that copy this and paste it and again
we're going to call change material
color for is active but this time we are
going to set the value to be equal to
one and compile and save this let me
just go back a compile and save that
there you go I don't know if I didn't
test it like this but let me just try it
out to see if this will work yeah you
see so yeah there you go as you can see
of course we are going to change another
color so we're going to change another
color but for that we also need to
create a timeline so don't worry about
that we will do that in a moment but as
you can see already we are changing the
color so first things first and let me
just stop this first things first we are
sending the value to zero waiting half a
second and then sending the value back
to one as you can see now how the color
goes as you can see to the red color so
this is essentially what we a small
effect not important for the game but it
gives a little bit crispy affective to
the game like you know it makes it look
a little bit better going back inside of
the player ball blueprint next we need
to create a time line so in order to
create a time line we simply right-click
and simply type time line like this and
here it is at the bottom add time line
and we're going to call it ball
activation time line and what is a time
line basically well first we're going to
drag a node over here to play and a time
line allows as you can see over here
time line node allows values to be
keyframed over time how does that work
we'll double click on the time line over
here and as you can see we have values
so you have a float value you have a
vector value you have a color track you
have a event track we're going to click
on the float track
and for the float track you can you know
give it the name whichever name you want
I don't know value simply type value
it's not important or float track or
whatever we also are going to set the
length over here to one so we're going
to have a one length and you can
right-click so let me just compile and
say that you can right click and you can
click add keyframe and you can click on
this keyframe
and for the time over here we're going
to set it at zero and value is zero
right click and add another keyframe and
the value for this keyframe is going to
be 1 1 so basically the time so when you
click on it the time is going to be 1
the value is going to be 1 this
basically means it will go or this float
will go from 0 to 1 in the time of 1
this is basically what we what is a
timeline so the value of this float will
go from 0 to 1 in length is 1 second
basically so this is what we are doing
over here so if we go back over here in
this time graph from the update and what
does this update in the timeline
basically the time it will take for that
float to go from the specified value
which is 0 to the goal value which is 1
so while that is happening this update
will be called and when that happens
from here we're going to say change ball
material color there you go so change
ball material color now the material
color is going to be from here I'm going
to take the power so get the power and
we're going to learn so I am going to
right click and I'm going to say lerp
and we want the lerp to be from a float
so not vector so power let me just see
over here lerp here it is this is the
one that we want and I'm going to break
it from here let me just move this a
little bit over here so that it is more
readable
so what's gonna happen over here this is
going to lurk from a which is zero to
the power value of the power is 100 if
you remember over here if you select the
power we set the default value to be 100
alpha over here is the time so the time
it will take to go from zero to 100 and
basically that time is going to be the
value over here from the time line and
we're going to set the return value over
here we're going to plug it in and the
parameter value is going to be the power
so the power compile and save if we go
over here we will see that we have a
power parameter which is controlling the
colors next when we finished so we're
here when you finish we are going to
call enable this able input so over here
when we finished we're going to call
this enable is going to be checked so
now we will be able to basically we will
be able to move so compile and save that
again what is happening so over here
everything that we we did explain some
you just select all of this create a
comment group and over here for the
comments so double click it we are going
to say change the color of the wall
there you go so compile and save this
bad boy so again from here we are
getting the material instance we explain
this
from here we're disabling the input we
explain that custom end that we have
created change the ball material color
we have it over here so it will change
the ball material instance the color
name over here and the parameter name
over here actually and it will set the
default value then it will set that
material to the ball meshes material so
over here
we are changing the material color for
is active to zero waiting half a second
then setting the material color for the
is active parameter to 1 then calling a
time line that will create a value this
float value that will go from 0 to 1 in
the time interval that we have already
explained and then we are going to use
that in the lerp function and lerp will
slowly go from this value to this value
over here in this time interval so it
will go from 0 to power which is 100
in the Alfa time and then we were going
to set that value for the power
parameter when everything finishes we
are going to enable the input so compile
and save that and if we go back over
here in our editor and if I hit play pay
attention now you see how the colors
have changed so again stop and then
click pause BAM it goes from no color to
red color to green color now of course
you can change or you can play with the
parameter values to extend the length so
that you can clearly or more clearly see
if you don't see the changes of color
for some reason so you can also extend
the value of the time it takes to do
that but you know I'm leaving up that
I'm leaving up to you for you to
experiment and yada yada yada basically
so yeah let's move forward the next
thing that we are going to do is create
the ball movement and before we start to
code that or blueprint that we need to
go here in our project settings and for
the input over here we need to create
our axis mappings and action mapping so
click on the plus button over here so
this one is going to be our first action
mapping and we're going to have a second
one and click on the plus button over
here for that taxi's mappings
so first things first over here for our
action one we're going to have jump and
for the jump we are going to filter here
in the search bar for the spacebar so
spacebar when we press on our keyboard
we are going to jump the next one over
here I'm going to call action and action
is going to be executed when we press
the e button on our keyboard so let me
just find it over here there you go so
when we press the e button on our
keyboard and we will be able to move the
elevator upwards as we saw in the
preview of this game and we will be also
able to move those boxes as well too so
they can come closer to us and so on and
so forth this will happen when we press
the e button now over here for our axes
we are going to say move right this is
going to be the name of the axis and now
over here not pressing this plus button
but pressing this plus button to add
another input so basically click here
and the first one is going to be
keyboard or key code a and the next one
is going to be key code D
for the keycode a we are also going to
add here - and there you go so this
basically means when we press the a or
the D key we will trigger this move
right axis mappings now what is this a
and B basically moving left and right -
one is for a because negative side left
side basically is the negative side
that's why we add here negative one so
now we can go in our ball player
blueprint and right here below this
change ball material color we are going
to create another custom event so right
click over here custom event and this
one is going to be move ment update or
movement however you want to call it
it's not that important but it's
important that you know what it is
so over here we are going to go in a
branch which is an if-else statement and
basically it will be true or false and
the condition over here is going to be
our puzzle mode so I'm going to plug it
in over here and if it's true we are
going to move our ball in one way if
it's false we're going to move it
another way so first over here I'm going
to right-click and we are going to say
set move direction like this and what's
gonna happen over here from the true I'm
going to drag it and I'm going to click
on this line for the note two times so I
can add another input over here so that
I can you know as you can see I can
visually set it or make it more clear
clear error to read clear or run out the
word anyways now over here we are going
to say get move right and from the move
right we are going to make a vector so
I'm going to say make vector and that
vector is going to go inside of the
x-axis and I'm going to plug it in over
here and this is basically we can move
this a little bit up just to make it a
little bit more clear to read and let me
just move it a bit down like this so
that it doesn't come close to this and
doesn't obscure it yada yada yada
anyways the next thing if it's false I'm
going to right click and from here again
we're going to say set move direction
like this and the false one will go
inside
over here and I'm going to double click
it again and move it down like this and
move this like this over here so if it's
false we are going to calculate it like
this we are first going to get and
actually I can move it up here because
we are going to calculate it over here
we're going to say get actor forward
vector like this so we're going to get
the actors forward vector and we're also
going to get the move right get move
right and we are going to multiply these
two so we're going to say from here x
float so we're going to multiply this
vector by this float and from there we
are going to normalize this vector so
normalize and from there we are going to
plug in this vector over here and if I
hover over it we'll say for the
normalize if you don't know what it is
gets a normalized unit copy of the
vector ensuring it is safe to do so
based on the length the return 0 vector
if vector length is too small to safely
normalize basically what will normalize
what normalized will do it will
stabilize the vector so to say it will
stabilize it and it will make the
movement little bit smaller that's the
best how I can explain it in
understandable terms so after that what
we are going to do let me just move this
a little bit here move this a little bit
here like this I mean it's readable so
everything is readable next what we are
going to do is from here we're going to
say add the movement input and from
there I'm going to plug this in like
this over here so go from here there you
go I'm going to double click this to
create to create a new line over here
and plug this one here as well so there
we go so now both of these are connected
to this one and lastly this one needs to
over here which means basically both of
these are leading the execution order to
the add movement input now the last
thing that we need to do is get the move
direction so we need to get it and we
need to normalize it so normalize and
now that we have normalized the move
direction
can plug it in over here and there you
go
so compile and save that basically again
what we are doing based on the puzzle
mode if it's true get the move right
make a vector out of it over here which
is basically going to create a vector
with the value for the X that we have
over here which is either 1 or negative
1 because over here you see we have
minus 1 or 1 and all other values are
going to be 0 and then we're going to
set that to the move Direction over here
if it's false then we're going to get
the actor forward vector then get the
move right multiply these two and from
there normalize the vector and plug it
into the move direction and over here
then we are going to add that move
Direction normalized to the add movement
input which is going to move our ball or
character and I'm going to right click
on this create a comment from section
and this one is going to be move meant
update there you go and you can compile
and save this now the last thing that we
need to do in order to make this work to
run it let me just move these comments
or these sections over here and probably
move this a little bit up over here
because now over here in the tick event
is where we are going to call the
movement update there you go because the
tick event is called every frame
basically it's like update in unity so
compile and save that and it will call
every frame this event or you can think
of it as a function as well and it will
execute all the code that we have just
explained so now we can go back over
here in our example map and if I hit the
play button and now you will see that
the ball is moving of course we cannot
jump and the ball is not rotating so the
next step will be to create that but the
ball as you can see can move left and it
can move right as well and we are moving
left by pressing a key and moving right
by pressing V key in the case of because
this is a 2.5 D platformer we are moving
forward and backwards backwards by
pressing a forward by pressing D you get
the point
yada-yada-yada if something is not clear
make sure to ask in the comment below so
that I can explain this before you
proceed to create other things that we
are going to do right now moving forward
the next
step is to go back in our player ball
and now that we are moving let us rotate
the ball and we're going to do that
right below the movement updates I'm
going to right click over here and
create another custom event and over
here I'm going to rename this one to a
rotate ball or something like that just
so that you know that this is used for
rotating the balls and also you can
think of these custom events something
similar like a function I already
mention that because you can basically
create him like this you can call them
over here of course we can as you can
see over here we have this place and you
know that basically this can allow us to
you have a delegate on this event but
I'm not going to go into that right now
we will do that in another video anyways
what we are going to do from the rotate
ball first thing from here I'm going to
drag a node and I'm going to set the
flat velocity and what we are going to
set in the flat velocity well first over
here I'm going to say get the velocity
so the law city and we are going to get
that from here target is the actor then
we are going to break this vector into
pieces so that we can have separate XY
and Z and from there we are going to
make a vector so from here I'm going to
say make vector which will create a new
vector that will allow us to plug in XY
and z so we're going to plug in the X
we're going to plug in the Y we're not
going to plug in the Z because we are
not moving so we're not moving the ball
like this we're moving it forward and
backwards so we're now going to plug in
the Z and we are going to plug this bad
boy over here so this is let me just
move these a little bit and this one
over here so so that we have you know
like a better visual representation of
the node because these nodes can get a
little bit tricky if you have too much
of these they can get messy and so on
and so forth same as like spaghetti code
you can have spaghetti nodes so you need
to be careful about that anyways moving
forward from here we are going to set
the current speed and for the current
speed we are going to set the length of
this vector so length and from here we
are going to say vector length here it
is so select the vector blank and pop
plug it
almost set pug it plug it in over here
as you can see the vector length is
basically this think of it as a vector
vector is like a XY and Z so x y and z
the length of the vector is we will use
the length of this line length of this
line and length of this line so it will
you know like form a single line out of
these three so that is the length of the
vector let me just compile and save this
so now that we have the current speed we
are going to go in a branch so from here
create a branch which we already know is
an if-else statement and we are going to
test the current speed so we're going to
get it and we are going to test if the
current speed is not equal to so it's
not equal to you notice I'm using the
exclamation mark and over here it will
make it not equal to and we are testing
it if it's not equal to zero basically
meaning that we are actually moving so
if it's not equal to zero that means we
are moving and if that is the case so if
it's true if it's false we're not going
to do anything but if it's true then we
are going to set the rotation amount and
the rotation amount is going to be
calculated like this first we are going
to get the flat velocity so get flat
velocity that we set over here so this
is our flat velocity then from the flat
velocity we are going to get the vector
length so it's length and I have issues
spelling length apparently so get the
vector length from the flat velocity and
after that we are going to divide that
by a float so over here divided by a
float and what is that float well the
float is going to be the ball rotation
rates of ball rotation rate so get the
ball rotation rate we know that we set
the ball rotation right over here to be
75 point 75 excuse me so there you go
now we are also going to get the PI so
simply type pi and I believe it's in the
kismet library let me just find it over
here not bendy but sometimes it's hard
to find things
you need a collision at collision where
is it here it is get pie here it is so
returns the value of pie and for the pie
we are going to multiply that so
multiply with the float and the float is
going to be the ball rotation rate and
from there we are going to plug this
into over here now
the next step that we are going to do is
from here we are going to go and
multiply this so multiply with a float
and the float that we are going to
multiply is going to be get world Delta
seconds and we're going to plug this in
bad boy over here and moving from there
we are going to add that so add a float
and not like here break the link but
here add the float and over here get the
rotation mount plug it in over here and
plug this in over here now of course we
are not done we have still too many
things to do I mean too many things just
a couple of things but going back over
here now this is one of the things that
I want to talk about now to be
completely honest going into detail how
this works and what this is I have no
idea but you know if you search online
how to rotate character how to rotate
upon how to calculations to do that you
will find many different solutions and
you just plug in sometimes I just plug
in a solution and it works this is just
to show you that you know you don't have
to know everything
I don't know behind the scenes how this
calculation work this is some I'm not
gonna say complex math but if you are
into math a little bit more you'll
probably understand this how or why we
are using or how we are using the vector
length of the flat velocity dividing
that by the P multiplied with the ball
rotation rate and then multiplying that
with the world
Delta seconds this is everything to
smooth things out we can basically
rotate the ball by just using get world
the Delta seconds multiplying that with
a ball rotation rate and it will work
you will probably be able to rotate the
ball just by using that so multiplying
the get world Delta seconds with the
ball rotation rate
then adding that to the rotation amount
and that will turn out just fine but
these extra calculations are just to
smooth things out but as I said like the
mat that goes behind is I don't know
completely so just to be honest so we
are going to leave it like here if
somebody knows he will explain in more
depth but this is just to show you that
you don't need to know every single
thing and every single aspect about game
development in order for you to be a
game developer so you can you know just
find some solutions online if they work
for you they work great then you can
just proceed you know further in your
game so what we are going to do next is
we are going to take the ball mesh and
from the ball mesh we are going to say
set world rotation like this and move
this a little bit here and plug this in
over here so what's gonna happen here or
the rotation that we are going to use is
we are going to get the flat velocity
yet flat velocity and from it we are
going to make a rotation from its ex so
basically from the x axis of the flat
velocity and sometimes I don't know why
Zarrella but anyways so we are going to
get from the flat velocity or create a
rotation from its x axis and from there
we are going to get the right vector
because we are rotating forward so we
are rotating in this direction and in
this direction so that's why we're
getting the right vector and from there
we are going to create a rotate tour
from axis and angle so we are going to
create you see creates a rotation from
on this and this is probably a miss or
how's it called misspelling or miss type
or type or whatever create a rotation
from this axis and supplied angle in
degrees so the axis is the right vector
from the X rotation from the flat
velocity and the angle is going to be
the rotation amount so get the rotation
amount and we are going to plug this
into over here compile and save that now
let me just take all of this right click
create a comment rotate the ball like
this
compiling
and we can go over here and call it
rotate ball so that we don't forget to
do that so we will need to call it here
in the tick in order to test it out if
we don't do that and it will not work
but going back over here how we are
getting the flat velocity split it
pretty clear we're getting the velocity
as you can see returns the velocity in
centimeters unreal unit seconds blah
blah blah basically what is velocity
there is velocity is speed over time so
the speed over time is how much the
velocity is so depending on the speed
over the time that's the velocity and
we're getting the velocity braking the
vector of the velocity getting the X and
the y and plugging that into flight
velocity this is pretty clear how we are
getting that we're getting from the flat
velocities vector like the current speed
and then from there if the speed is not
equal to null because if the if we are
not moving the length of this flat
velocity will be zero and then we will
not go inside of this branch and we will
not rotate the ball but if we are moving
then the vector length will be greater
than zero so from there we did this all
of this here as I already said but
probably I didn't test it out but I'm
pretty sure that you can just rotate the
ball by using get world Delta seconds
multiplying that with the ball rotation
rate and adding that to the rotation
amount you can try it out and then from
here we are getting again from the flat
velocity we are getting the creating a
rotation from its x axis and getting the
right vector from there and creating a
rotator or a rotation from that angle
and that axis and plugging that into our
rotation set world rotation for the ball
which means that we can basically go now
over here and I can hit the play button
and you will see now that if we move you
see how the ball is rotating and notice
how the ball is rotating only you see
when we go left it is rotating backwards
if we go forward it is rotating forward
so that is why we're using that get
right vector this right over here get a
right vector that's why we're using that
because we are rotating here in this
direction and
in this direction we are not rotating up
or down or like this and like this so
again if I run it you will see now pay
attention the ball is rotating moving
forward now we are going to create the
jump for our ball because well we cannot
progress in our level without it so over
here right below the rotate ball I am
going to right click and we are going to
get the jump which is the input action
here it is input action jump now what we
are going to do is when we press it's
over here I'm going to go in a branch
and what I'm going to test here in this
condition is if we are falling and we're
going to get that from the character
movement so here is the character
movement component over here at the top
it can detect if we are falling or not
which is the beauty so from here we can
say is falling let me just get it here
it is and I can plug it in over here so
if we are not falling so if that is
false we are going to say jump simple as
that so there you go compile and save
that so again the character movement
component has some built in features it
can jump as you can see over here target
is character it can jump on its own it
can also detect if we are falling down
from the sky or basically falling down
from the air so we can use that from the
character movement if we are falling so
if that is false then we can jump and we
can test this out right away we can go
back over here we can hit the play
button we can move as you can see now I
can jump pay attention you see bam bam
we can jump but well as you can see as
you can see the ball is not jumping that
high what we need to do is select the
character movement and change some
things over here such as the gravity
scale for example we are going to set
that to 3.5 we are also going to set
over here max tap height we are going to
leave that
so walkable floor angle we can leave
that set at 45 just to a random number
maximum walk speed I'm going to set that
to 800 instead of 600 I'm also going to
check this check box can walk off
when crouching which basically means
that we can walk off ledges also over
here ball or jump Z velocity over here
it's at 420 I'm going to set that to
1000 and 800 and over here air control
we are going to set that to 1 so if you
hover over one falling amount of ladder
movement control available to the
character 0 no control 1 full control at
max speed so basically we are giving
full control to the character of the
ball when he is falling also hope you
over here at the bottom for the maximum
custom movement speed I'm going to set
that to 800 basically all these things
are self-explanatory so maximum movement
speed custom movement speed basically
how maximally the speed can be by which
we are moving over here for the air
control we already explained that jumps
even lost initial velocity so basically
on the Z when we jump how high that
velocity is can walk off ledges when
crouching we already explained that so
on and so forth yada yada yada we don't
have to explain all of that because as I
said there self explainatory so now we
can go back over here in our game and
hit the play button and when we jump now
the ball is jumping higher as you can
see and everything seems perfectly fine
and it is except when we get over here
to this edge we cannot bounce off of it
and we saw that when we jump on the edge
or on the ledge over here that we are
able to jump from another ledge to
another ledge as you saw in the preview
from here to here to here to here so on
and so forth but we cannot do that how
can we actually do that well for that we
need to create something called a line
trace by channel so we need to go back
over here and from the true meaning if
we are falling which means we are
already in the air we have jumped so if
that is true we are going to say line
trace by trace by channel there you go
and I'm going to move this a little bit
over here because we have some
calculations to do the line trace by
channel will trace a line from the start
till the end that it will give us a here
if we hit something so from where to
where we are going to trace that line
first things first we are going to get
the actor forward vector so over here
right click get actor for word vector
there you go
and I think I need to move this a little
bit further over here because we will
have some calculations over here so what
we are going to do now is from the actor
forward vector we need to do some
calculations over here we're going to
multiply him so multiply him with a
float and what float is that going to be
well first let me just set this like
this over here now I am going to get the
capsule component so getting the capsule
component and from the capsule component
I'm going to get the skilled skilled
sphere radius or get scaled capsule
excuse me scaled capsule radius why did
I say sphere because this is a capsule
this will return the capsule radius
scaled by the component scale so
basically the scale of the radius or
capsule radius is 75 we are going to
scale it by the radius and the radius is
basically 1 so that is what we are
component scale which is basically the
scale of the component which is 1 so
after that we are going to say from here
plus float and we are going to add to it
10 so the value of 10 and this is the
value that you are going to plug in over
here to multiply with the vector with
the actor forward vector because now let
me just move these a little bit down
here I can get the so I can say get
actor location and what we need to do is
from here we need to subtract so we need
to say minus vector and we are
subtracting it from here and the line
trace can go over here and this is the
start of our line trace there you go now
where is going to be the end of our line
trace well from here again I'm going to
multiply this with a float but again let
me just click on it over here something
like this
skin do I'm going to move this bad boy
over here again we need to get the
capsule component here you go
and get skilled capsule radius again
some of it over here and again we're
going to add to it
ten so plug this in over here I
basically just copy and paste in this
you can select it you can control C
command C on Mac and control V command V
on Mac and after that we are going to
and I think I can move these down just
so that they are a little bit better to
read so like this yeah this can work so
then we are going to plug this in over
here but this time we are as you can see
we are multiplying everything but this
time over here we are going to get the
actor location so copy and paste the
actor location and here we are
subtracting but now we are adding so
plus vector and plug this in over here
there you go and this one goes over here
for the end trace there you go so this
is the beginning and the end of our
trace and what this will do is create
that trace line for the so compile and
save that this will create the trace
line from the ball so if the ball is
here and since I add a 10 over here it's
basically going to create a trace line
like this so this is the trace line that
is going to be created from here to here
and it is going to detect anything that
we touch within that trace line so
what's gonna happen after that is that
we are going to go in a branch and we
are going to detect if we have touched
something so here return value it's
going to be plugged in the condition
which means basically if we did touch
something because you see here does a
collision trace along the given line and
returns the first blocking hit
encountered so if we have a return value
if we have a return value true if there
was a hit false otherwise
that means true we have a hit
after that from this true we are going
to go over here and we're going to
launch the character so launch the
character now what this will do is as
you can see set a pending launch
velocity on the character this velocity
will be processed on the next character
movement component tick and we'll set it
the falling and and we'll set it to the
falling state so yeah basically what
this means it will propel the character
simple as that but as you can see the
explanations here can be complicated but
this will just propel the character now
what we are going to do is from our out
over here what we are going to do is we
are going to break the hit results this
hit result as you can see this will be
that game object or that actor whatever
that we hit with this line trace and
what we are going to do with it is over
here I'm going to right click and I'm
going to say get actor location I'm
going to right-click over here on the
return value and click on split
structure so that we can have x y&z
separately and I'm going to take the X
and I'm going to subtract from it so I'm
going to say minus float and the float
that I'm going to minus it from is going
to be from this location right click and
split the pin structure and we are going
to take the X and plug it in over here
the last thing that we need to do is
take this and create a sign out of it
so the signed value as you can see
returns minus 1 if a is greater than 0 0
if a is 0 and plus 1 if a is greater
than 0 I will show you what this will do
and from here I am going to multiply
that with the float so multiply it with
the float and basically this is the
amount by which we are going to propel
the character so let's say 800 and we
are going to plug that in for the launch
velocity or actually excuse me delete it
promote to variable or actually split
the pin structure so this goes in the
launch velocity for the X the Z launch
velocity is going to be 1000 and 400 and
we are going to override all
the axis overriding all the axis
basically means that we will use this
new velocity for it simple as that so
just use the new velocity and there you
go so compile and save that now one
thing that we can also do is use this
debug draw the bug type and we can say
this persistent and compile and save
that just that we can see the line trace
that's being drawn so did you see it
here it is this is the line trace that
is being drawn so again there you go you
see this is what we are doing there you
go we are drawing these lines and as you
can see as I said there's something like
this so this is the line where we are
drawing it why is this important because
now when we go over here we will be able
to touch these and we can bounce off of
them you see you see now how we can
bounce off of these but before that we
will not we were not able to do that now
the reason why we are able to do that
because as you said this right here now
makes it a little bit is a little bit
clearer because you saw the line that is
being drawn so the line is being drawn
from this calculation and this is an
arbitrary number that I added so it's
not like you always add 10 and it will
be perfect no you can experiment this
you can add 15 20 30 40 50 or a
gazillion but you get the point and we
need to you know go back from here this
is the start and this is the end so
that's why I subtract it over here and
add it over here because the end needs
to be greater and the start needs to be
smaller so that it can start from here
and go up to here for example now we can
remove this we don't need to draw it
again and this right here we explain
what it is this is pretty clear we got
from the hit the details from the hit
the object that we hit we got its
location X we are subtracting that
location X from our own actor and the
location X from the actor that we hit
now what is this sign well basically
this sign will stabilize our character I
don't know how to explain it better
except by showing you so
I'm going to break the link over here
and I'm going to plug this in over here
just so you can see what's gonna happen
if we don't have this sign and let's go
over here and now you're going to see
what's gonna happen if we don't have
this sign to stabilize our character in
the air when I say character I mean the
ball but it can be any other character
now notice now when I jump back
you see I've jumped off that cliff or
the edge of the cliff where I was and it
can happen the same thing can happen
over here you see actually I cannot jump
on that so let's try it again over here
again when I jump you saw before we test
it out it worked perfectly we will we
were able to bounce off of this but now
you see this so that's why we're using
this sign to practically stabilize our
character in the air so compile and save
that this will stabilize it in the air
how that math works behind the scenes I
have no idea don't even try to ask me
but this as you can see will stabilize
the character and if I go back again you
will notice so anytime you need some
stabilization especially in the air you
can use that sign to convert that float
into a more stabilized value because now
as you can see pay attention it only
allows it to go to minus 1 and 1 as you
can see if I have our overlit returns
minus 1 if a is greater then X's if a is
less than zero excuse me zero
if a is zero and plus 1 if a is greater
than zero so it will stabilize it will
allow it to be between minus 1 and 1 and
that's why our jump now is working and
we can bounce off that rock or how I
want to call it when we come close to
because otherwise you saw what happened
we we got propelled like a gazillion
years in time but yeah this is for our
jump the last step that we can do is you
know I can actually now select all of
this and we can move it a little bit
back so something like this and we can
select it right-click create a comment
play your jump we can call it like this
compile and save that so yeah play it's
actually play or not blah err
it's play your jump there you go
compile and save that and we don't have
to call this with the tick event because
you know we just need to press the
function press the button that is
connected to this function in order for
us to jump but yeah anyways this is how
we can utilize the jump in order to you
know jump smoothly with our ball okay
the next step is to go back in our
player ball blueprint and right here
below create another custom event so
this one is going to be so custom event
and this one is going to be power damage
there you go just come closer to this
bad boy now what is this going to do
basically we're going to have power when
we pull together the cube that we have
in our game that we saw in the preview
so when we pull it we have power that
will be drained when we do that now this
power is going to have an input which is
a parameter and it's going to be a float
and that one is going to be damaged like
this there we go so compile and save
that what we are going to do is from
here we're simply going to set the power
so set power but to which value are we
going to set it to well the value is
going to be we are going to take over
here the damage and we are going to
multiply that so multiply the damage and
what am i typing over here so multiply
the damage would the get world so right
click get world Delta seconds there you
go and plug this bad boy in over here so
we are going to get the world Delta
seconds multiply the damage with that
and we are going to get the power the
current value of the power and we know
if we select the power over here the
default value is 100 so from here we are
going to say minus float and we are
going to subtract this value so we're
going to subtract the damage that we
pass as a parameter over here multiplied
with the get world Delta seconds now
also what we are going to do is we are
going to clamp this value so clamp the
float and the value is going to be this
is the value that we want to clamp and
the value is going to be 4
minimum to maximum which is 100 like
this and that is what is going to be set
to the power now what is clamp well
clamp basically if you hover over
returns the value clamp between a and B
inclusive and that's enough explanation
for you to get confused but basically
clamp means it will make sure that this
value over here will not go below this
value and it will not go above this
value so this is what we are doing so it
will not go below this and not above
this and next we are putting that into
the power the next step from here is to
and let me see what we have over here so
next we have the change change ball
material color and over here the
material color is going to be changed by
using the power plugging in the power
over here and the parameter value is
going to be power so make sure that it's
capital P and if you're not sure can go
back in the material itself and take or
get that value the name of it that is
next we are going to go inside of a
branch so branch there you go which is
an if-else statement and the condition
for the branch is going to be taking the
power over here we are going to test if
the power is less than or equal to if
the power is less than or equal to one I
actually zero excuse me not 100 so if
the power is less than or equal to zero
that means we don't have any more power
we have died so from here if that is
true we are going to say set is that
check the check box to make it true and
from there we are going to change ball
material color and the material name or
parameter name is going to be is on and
the value is going to be zero which is
going to you know make it look like we
have died it is going to turn off the
ball and last but not least we are going
to enable this able input and make sure
that this check box is not checked so
compile and save that so let me just try
to click create a comment section and
this is power damage now again
and I don't think that there is a lot of
things that we need to explain over here
because this is everything is basic just
subtracting and multiplying and so on
and so forth basic things this is to
smooth the value out so multiplying the
damage with the world Delta seconds to
smooth the value out because if we pass
here the damage to be I don't know five
it will subtract pretty quickly if we
subtract it directly from the power
especially if it happens multiple times
you know in a second for example but
when we use get world Delta seconds it
will make a little bit slower so it will
smooth things out and here we are
changing the material color we saw that
in the beginning we explained all that
so I don't think there is a need to do
it again but if isn't if something is
not clear make sure to ask in the
comment below and last but not least we
have another custom event and we will
test these two out shortly we will come
back to these two don't worry about that
because we cannot test them right now
and this one custom event energy damage
this is the name of it as I said we
cannot test that these two functions
right now or events power damage and
energy damage because we will need to
have the ball actually we will need to
have the cube and we will have the
lasers but before that we are going to
have the UI to display that to the user
everything will come shortly don't worry
about that and I will revisit this again
to explain it so over here again we are
going to have an input which is the
damage parameter and what's gonna happen
is from here we are going to set the
energy here is our energy node and the
value we are going to set it to we are
going to multiply with a float and click
here to add another pin because we're
going to have three inputs over here the
first one is going to be get world Delta
seconds as you can see over here plug
this in over here and for the third one
we're simply going to say 1 and then we
can move this over here
get the energy and the default value of
the energy by the way is 100 as you can
see over here and now that we have the
energy we are going to subtract from it
and so minus float and now that we have
that
we are going to plug this in over here
and clamp the value which is last thing
that we need to do clamp the float and
we are going to clamp this value between
0 and 100 same thing as what we did with
our with the power above so going back
over here plugging it in over here and
there you go compile and save that now
what's specific here for this energy I'm
just gonna create a comment over here in
energy damage over here I'm going to say
positive values are equal damage and
negative values are equal to heal so
when we pass a pass a positive number in
the damage over here then what we are
going to do is we are going to basically
we're going to deal damage when we pass
the negative value we are going to heal
that and your assignment is to comment
below how does that actually work so
make sure that you for example pass here
10 and then minus 10 and see how that
works you can use print and so on and so
forth but I want you to figure and dig
deeper into that and see how that works
now we do need to take this energy
damage and what did I do and we need to
go over here inside of our tick event
and from here we need to call energy
damage and what's gonna happen over here
the damage value is going to be negative
25 because as I said the negative value
over here as you can see positive values
equal damage negative values equals
he'll compile and save that but as I
said make sure that you dig in
experiment use the print function or
print however you want to call it to
print out the values over here the
energy you can do that by creating
another node and so on and so forth but
I don't want to give you any more tips
because I want you to investigate that
and for you tax or see it now
unfortunately as I said we are not able
to test this out right away we still
need to create the lasers we need to
create a cube and we need to create the
UI and when we do that we will come back
to revisit these lines of No
or code to explain them again what is
happening so let us now create our game
Hut so we're going to right-click over
here in the blueprints and we are going
to go under user interface and we're
going to create a widget blueprint and
we are going to call this bad boy BP
underscore underscore not plus game Hut
there we go
and double click this to open it over
here and voila this is what we need now
of course we're still not finished what
we want is a progress bar so we want one
progress bar we want another progress
bar and we want a text there we go and
is it a rich text block or a simple text
actually a simple text not a rich text
block so we can delete this and we just
want the text okay so the progress bar
first one over here is going to be the
power bar the second one over here is
going to be the energy bar and the text
over here is going to be our interact
text so I'm going to just leave it like
this for now but what we are going to do
well first things first the anchor for
this power bar which is basically a
slider is going to stay at the top left
corner now the position X is going to be
20 for the position Y 20 for the width
and the height so size X - 5 6 size Y -
4 there you go so this is how it looks
like pay attention look a very nice
slider
yada-yada-yada now what we are also
going to do is for the style click on
the drop down list and we have the under
scale style we have the background image
and we have this tint color now the tint
color for this one is going to be red so
let me just click on it over here and
linear hex color yeah here it is
red so there you go this is going to be
the tint color for our for the power
bars it is the power bar a power bar
excuse me so I forgot and for this one
so going down over here the appearance
fill color and opacity click on that one
and over here we are going to have the
green one now just one second I
this quickly so this is over here the
hex linear color that you need to type 0
D F F 0 0 F F this is for the green one
you can pause it to type it out and for
the red one is over here let me just go
and show you it's ff0000 F F but you
know you don't have to do it exactly
like I'm doing but if you want to follow
along everything there you go
also over here for the percent is you
can see we can move it left and right so
zero over here is well zero and when we
are moving it to the one so this is how
we are going to leave it so that is how
it is going to look like this is for the
power bar now going back to the energy
bar so let's select the energy bar we
are also going to leave the anchor at
the top left corner and over here I'm
going to set the position X to 20 for
the position y is going to be 56 the
size x 1 to 8 and the size y 24 there
you go now for this bad boy we're also
going to change the color so let's go
over here under style click on this one
and for the hex linear paste in over
here 0 0 0 a 0 C F F or simply pause the
video and copy and paste it then click
on ok now for the color which is the
regular color over here we are going to
leave it as is so now if you go over
here you see now this is what we have so
when you move the percent there you go
compile and save this bad boy last but
not least for the text block what we are
going to do is we are going to set the
anchor at the top center so this is
where the anchor is going to be as you
can see over here
the position X for our bad boy over here
is going to be negative 1 to 8 so
negative 128 40 for the position Y the
size for the X is going to be 2 5 6 to
256 and the size ex-excuse me 256 the
size Y is 40 there you go we're going to
align the text in the
middle and simply over here we're going
to say II like in quotes in single quote
single quote a single quote to interact
there you go so this is what we have
compiled and save that now again this is
not something that you know you need to
follow strictly what I did you can
experiment with these you can even
create a better slider than these that I
have created so be my guest and
experiment this is what I want you to do
that's how you learn the best now what
we need to do in order for this and let
me just close this ball material yes
close it yeah I don't care what we need
to do in order to spawn this bad boy
inside of our game is go over here in
our game mode and previously in the
beginning of the level if you remember
when we deleted here from our level
blueprint and we set over here open
level blueprint we delete it from here
to notes well these two notes were
actually spawning the UI inside of the
game so these two nodes were spawning
the UI in the game and we can do it
either here we can also do it over here
in the game mode it's not important so
in the game mode in the event graph over
here we can delete a tick event and in
the beginning play we can do something
like create widget like this so create
the widget and the widget that we want
to create is B P game hut and after that
add to viewport and who are we adding to
viewport well the returning value which
we are going to put over here and there
you go so simply compile and save this
bad boy so again over here just create
UI widget and from the class we can
select the one that we have created over
here which is our BP game HUD there you
go and from there we simply need to add
it to viewport to make it visible and
who are we adding to the viewport the
returning value that's been created from
this class over here so if we were to go
now in our example man hit the play
button there we go we have our UI at the
top left corner we have the power bar we
have the energy bar and in the middle we
see that we have
to interact now of course this e to
interact will not be visible right away
from the beginning instead when we come
close to the interactable game objects
or actors but in order to do that we of
course need to do a couple of other
things so the first thing that we need
to do is go back over here inside of our
game HUD and we can close the game mode
and next you have the designer and the
graph over here if you take a look at
the top right corner so we are currently
in the designer where we can you know
design this but when we go in the graph
this is where the notes are being
constructed so what we need to do is we
can delete this pretty construct and in
the construct the first thing that we
are going to do is get a player
reference over here I'm going to click
the plus button and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to say player play year re
F there you go and this is going to be
our player characters or ball how did I
name the player B P player ball so
object reference from him also over here
let me go back in the designer and
select the text over here e to interact
and when you select it over here at the
top you have this is variable is
variable so click on that and compile
and say that the reason is because we
also want to make that text block
variable and you can rename it to
interact text or something like that can
I click it over here actually we need to
rename it over here text block 25
interact text there you go so compile
and save that then when you go back over
here there you go we have the interact
text now what we need to do is we need
to take the player reference and set it
so how can we set it well first things
first we need to get the player pong
player pawn and from the player pawn we
are going to go over here cast ubp
player ball and who are we casting we're
casting the player pawn if that is
successful if it works then we are going
to set the returning value as a
reference to the player character that
we have just over here created after
that inside of our player character
blueprint we need to go over here and at
the bottom you see over here we have the
HUD reference well now we need to change
this type variable from boolean to game
HUD BP game Hut and go over here object
reference compile and save that and
there you go so now also make sure that
it is a public variable so that we can
now access it over here because now what
we are going to do is from our player
reference so take the player player
reference and from here we are going to
say set hut
so set HUD reference and this is gonna
go over here so the execution or it goes
over here and who are we going to set
well we're going to set this game hot
blueprint and for that we are going to
type self and over here get a reference
to self and plug it in over here now
what the hell is this self self
basically means it refers to itself so
it is referring to this game HUD
blueprint now over here we need to do
one more thing which is call another
function that we still didn't create so
let's go quickly create them over here
like right below the tick event and in
the tick event we will do another thing
so over here we have custom event and
we're going to have two custom events
I'm going to copy and paste this one so
I'm going to select this custom event
and come on can you just why isn't this
working for some reason I cannot rename
it I don't know why there you go so show
show interaction text there you go
another custom event right-click custom
event hide interaction text there you go
now what we are going to do is simply
get the text or interact text there you
go from here we're simply going to say
set visibility and plug this in over
here
plug it in over here the visibility if
it's show we're going to make it visible
copy and paste it if it's not
we are going to set it to hidden there
you go
so compile and save that and what we
need to do at the top over here after we
set a reference to the UI Hut in the
player blueprint from here we're going
to hide the interaction text which means
now let me just compile and save that
and if we go back over here in our
example name hit the play button you see
we don't have the interaction text
previous it was here if you remember a
moment ago it was there but now we don't
have it because well now we are hiding
it so we are doing that with these two
events now what's gonna happen here
inside of Arctic in the tick we're going
to take the player and we're going to
test if he is valid so is valid but we
want this one with a question mark not
the one with the F mark but the one with
a question mark and this goes over here
so if the player character is valid
which means we have a player he is not
dead
we are going to take the power bar from
here get the power bar and we're going
to say set percent and this goes over
here and the percent that we are going
to set for the power bar is going to be
from our player so we are going to get
the player and from the player we are
going to get the power and after that so
we have the player we have the power
then we are going to divide that by
float and that division is going to be
by 100 and then plug it in over here y
by 100 so compile save that if we go
back over here if we take the power bar
pay attention now so over here where is
the here is the percent as you can see
it goes the value goes from 0 up to 1 so
if the power value is 100 we need to
divide that by 100 in order to get the
number between 0 and 1 because if it's
90 if the power drops to 90 if we divide
that by 100 that means point 9 so on and
so forth you get the point and we're
going to do the exact same thing for the
energy bar so going over here first
we're going to take the energy bar
get it set percent exactly the same
thing we're doing but this time for the
energy bar so plug this in over here
this goes over here and now getting the
player reference getting the energy so
get energy there you go and the energy
also needs to be divided by a float and
that division is going to happen with
100 again for the same reason plug this
in over here and make sure that you
compile and saved and now this is in the
tick event for the UI hut which means we
don't have to do anything else the tick
is being updated on its own and
basically it will also update this when
the players energy and power updates of
course if we go back over here we test
this out nothing will happen because we
don't have the lasers who are
subtracting energy from us we don't have
the cube that we need to move that are
gonna subtract our power so on and so
forth so the next step is to start
creating them moving forward the next
thing that we want to create is our
laser so over here in the blueprints we
are going to right click and create a
blueprint class and it is going to
inherit from the actor and this is going
to be BP underscore laser and inside of
the laser first we are going to set the
laser so select the default scene or
route and from here add a component
which is going to be a particle system
component there you go
so this is going to be our particle
system let me just go back over here
where our objects are and why for some
reason is this not slowing down and when
I say this I mean the movement of my the
movement of the mouse and stuff like
that so yeah anyways for the particle
system over here where it says particles
over here for the template click on the
drop down list and we want the
electricity arc this one this is the one
that we want now this one are actually
the P electricity arc let me just find
over here arc like this here it is the P
underscore electors to the arc not
directly elect
the ark so this is the one that we want
so compile and save that and basically
yeah we don't have to change anything
else we can leave it as is and there you
go now if we go back here inside of our
example map and what I'm going to do is
let me just go over here in the world
outliner I want to create a new folder
and that folder is going to be lazers
who's going to hold our lasers and I'm
going to put this first laser over here
and I'm going to put it under this one
so under the folder and the position for
the laser is going to be 734 the X for
the Y is 0 and for the Z 821 there you
go
voila so this is where our laser is
going to be now if we were to run the
game of course nothing's gonna happen we
were just gonna come here close you're
going to see the laser like this but the
laser needs to fire like this over here
not like this so in order to fix that we
do need to go back over here in our
laser actor and come in side of the
event graph and using we don't need a
begin overlap we don't need begin play
we need the tick event from here and for
the laser what we need to do here we
need to create two variables first one
is going to be trace
max max length and we also need laser
direction so laser Direction laser
direction is going to be a vector which
is going to determine the direction of
the laser and the trace max length is
going to be a float so compile and save
that because now for the trace maximum
length we need to set the value for it
so the value the default value is going
to be 100,000 so 100,000 is going to be
for the maximum length and what we need
to do over here in the tick event we are
going to you create a line trace by
channel same as what we did with our
ball that was enabling us to jump but
this time we are doing this with the
laser so that we can detect the
and actually deal damage with or to the
player so over here I am going to get
the actor location and this is the
location of the current actor which is
our laser what do I need with the
location well over here we need to get
the laser direction and we also need to
get this trace max length and we need to
add or actually first multiply these two
so first over here the laser direction x
float and the float is going to be trace
max length that is going to be
multiplied with and then we are going to
add two vectors so the actor location
vector plus vector this is what you want
adding to the product of these two so
now when they are added this is going to
be our end trace channel and the start
trace channel is going to be the actor's
position directly or the actor's
location so as you can see and we
already know how the line trace by
channel works we saw that with the ball
but again as I am you know just briefly
explaining it so the start is from the
actors location and the end is from the
laser direction multiplied with the três
três maximum length plus 2 the actor's
location which means it's gonna be way
over here and it's gonna you know shoot
that line and what's gonna happen from
here is that we are going to go in a
branch and we know that a branch is an
if-else statement the condition is going
to be the return value meaning if we hit
something it is going to well be
returned now also what we are going to
do is if we if the hit value is true we
are going to set the from the particle
system over here we are going to set the
beam source set beam source point here
it is and the beam source point is
basically from where the being is going
to start so if it's true we are going to
put it over here
now the new source point is actually
going to be the actor location so we can
copy and paste this bad boy over here
and I can move this over here and I can
plug this in over here so the new source
point is going to be the actor location
or the location of the current or the
whole actor holding holding this
particle emitter now also what we want
to do is from here from our out hit we
want to break this break the hit point
and this can be a little bit over here
and over here just for readability
purposes so to say next what we also
need to set is we have the beam source
point we also need to set the beam
target point so from here we are going
to say but first we need to get the
particle system so copy and paste the
particle system and from here we are
going to say set beam so set beam target
point so the source is where the beam is
starting but the target is where the
beam is going to hit so like his last
destination the last destination is
going to be the location of the hit that
we well got from the line trace channel
so that is going to be the new target
point next what we want to do is from
here from the other actor or the hit
actor from here we want to cast to the
VP player ball try to cast it so we are
going to say cast ubp player ball like
this so we are trying to do that and we
need to get from here the hit actor and
plug him in over here let me just double
click this bad boy so that we can do it
like this as you can see we are taking
the hit actor the hit actor is basically
what we hit or touched with the line
trace channel if that is castable or if
we can cast him into a BP player ball
that means we hit the ball and if we hit
the ball what we need to do is we need
to get from the ball the power damage
from here we're going to say power
damage as you can see which is our
function and the damage is going to be
50 and I can compile and save that there
you go and if I go over here in our
player ball and this is our energy
damage this is the power damage so we're
going to take the damage multiply it
with the world
get world Delta seconds then subtract
from the power then set the value over
here and then use the change ball
material color yadda yadda yadda you get
the point but what's even prettier error
is that we can go here in our gamehud
and over here in the thick event we are
using the power to set the percent and
we can see all that visually being
represented now so before we go back
again and briefly explain what is going
on over here even though I don't think
there is a need but I will go briefly
like in a minute or in a second
explaining everything what is what is
happening but if I go back over here and
hit the play button notice now the power
so pay attention at the top left corner
and let me just take a look at oh yeah
silly stupid stupid a teacher me you see
what I forgot over here I mean you don't
but over here the laser Direction
compiled and say that the laser
Direction for the X next needs to be
negative 1 or otherwise this will not
work because we're using over here the
laser Direction so as you can see
multiplying with the Tres max length if
the if the laser Direction is 0 0 0 on
three axes if we multiply that with any
number it's gonna be 0 so it's not gonna
work also another thing that we need to
do is go in the player ball and select
his capsule component and over here for
the collision we need to change this
collision from the pawn to custom and
over here we need to have the collision
enabled to query in physics and we can
also block all over here it's not
important but what's important is that
we have this query and physics so
collision enabled basically
and if we don't have this then we will
not collide and I can just demonstrate
that quickly so if we have a pawn over
here like it was a moment ago if I hit
the play button and go now to test this
out it will basically not work there you
go
nothing is working and voila but if we
go back and select the capsule component
set this to custom and put it to
collision and any bolt and we can block
everything it's unimportant compile and
save that so if we back or go back now
and hit the play button so now when I
come over here pay attention at the top
left corner notice now how the laser is
well destroy me and also you will notice
how the laser when he touches me when he
touches the ball and pay attention I
cannot move now I'm that when he touches
the ball he's like cut out he goes only
to the ball so the laser goes from here
for example if he touches the ball over
here he goes only to here he doesn't go
above the ball as you can well see and
if I go back over here and the reason
why it cuts out on the ball is because
of this beam target point is set to the
brake hit result or the hit result that
we have from here and it's location so
there you go and if we have the player
we are getting his power damage and what
we are doing we are calling it by using
damage 50 and we saw what's happening so
we saw at the top left corner and this
over here we saw it how it's being
calculated so on and so forth
yada-yada-yada I've already explained
that so basically yeah if something is
not clear by any chance I believe we
explain everything over here and in the
ball we already explained what is
happening something is not clear just
make sure to ask and I will you know
help you out but before we you know like
proceed on other parts we are also going
to copy and paste this laser because we
are going to have another one so this
laser is going to be at the position X 4
7 6 7 9 for the position y 0 and for the
position Z is 2 6 1 1 there you go so
this one is going to be over here
as you can see now we are going to copy
and paste this one as well because we
are going to have the third one and the
position X for the third line is going
to be seven six eight zero and zero zero
for the or zero for the y and for the Z
it's going to be two four four eight
there you go
so compiled or actually say the current
that if I hit the play button let me
just eject myself and if I go over here
there you go so pay attention now we
have these two lasers over here and of
course we will need our cubes in order
to you know overcome them which well
will be the next thing that we are going
to create so inside of the blueprint
folder we are going to right-click and
create a blueprint class which is going
to inherit from the actor and this is
going to be B P underscore inter in
interactive hopefully I can spell there
you go
interactive block double click the bad
boy what we need to do first things
first select the interactive block here
over here at the top click on add
component and filter for the physics
physics constraint there you go and drag
the physics constraint to be the root
object now what the hell is a physics
constraint if you hover over this is
effectively a joint that allows you to
connect two rigid bodies together
basically it will allow us to pull the
cube easier with the ball simple as that
so what we are going to do first here
the component name for our physics
constraint we are going to say here
collision for one now also what I'm
going to do is over here for the linear
limits I am going to set everything to
be free so linear limits means we can
linearly indicate the linear constraint
applied along the x axis basically if we
can move our constraint on the linear x
axis linear Y so on and so forth over
here for the swing one motion we are
going to have it locked and over here
it's free for the swing two motion
with motion we'll also be free and I
think that's all there is to it that's
all there is to that we need to do so
compile and save that next select the
physics constraint and filter for our
static mesh component so filter over
here static mesh there it is and I'm
simply going to call it mesh which is
going to contain our cubes you can click
here where it says over here to add that
mesh and filter for the cube rounded so
this is the one that we want the cube
around that there you go now what I'm
also going to do is over here for the
cube we need to check this simulate
physics check box and for the mass in kg
over here from 100 are going to set it
to 3,000 linear damping we are going to
set that to 2 and now you can hover over
and see what it is drag force added to
reduce linear movement so you a lot of
these things but basically all of these
things are self explanatory so you can
you know just hover over and see what
they are over here for the collision we
are going to check this simulation
generates hit events and over here for
the collision presets we are going to
leave that to physics actor but over
here for the physics material we are
going to select the slide physics
material and what the hell is this well
if you double click on it and if you go
inside this is basically a physics
material that will allow the cube to
slide when we start dragging it smoother
you see the friction is zero meaning it
will not have any friction when we move
it as you can see over here override
friction combined restitution Sun and so
forth but basically when you play with
these settings depending on the friction
mostly because the friction is when the
actor is being dragged over another
actor so how they touch each other will
there will there be friction or not when
it's zero well it's not zero zero there
is no friction which means this one will
slide
think of it like if you have
game for example where you want to
create ice or an ice terrain well you
will use zero for friction because ice
is slippery
there you go so now we have our mesh
next what we need to do is select the
mesh and for the mesh I am also going to
add so before we do anything I'm over
here on the z axis I'm going to set it
to negative two seven eight
there you go and also what I'm going to
do is on the Box extent or actual this
is for the trigger detection excuse me
this this will be for the trigger that
we are going to add to the mesh excuse
me for that so first select the mesh and
filter for the box collision so there
you go this is where I made a mistake so
the Box collision or we are going to
rename it to detection trigger there you
go so this is my mistake and now what we
are going to do with this bad boy is now
we are going to on the z axis to say
negative two seven eight to set the
value a little bit down as you can see
what I'm also going to do is here for
the Box extent X is going to be 1000 so
1000 Y is going to be 130 and Z is going
to be 300 there you go
which is going to well look like this so
it looks like this and compile and save
this bad boy now last but not least we
are also going to select the mesh and
attach a particle particle particle so
here it is particle system and I'm going
to click on this bad boy and this is
going to be our beam there you go
and I'm it's not important to capitalize
the B but I'm going to capitalize it so
over here for the template now we are
going to select the electricity arc so
electricity arc not the one like we did
if I type Erik over here not P
underscore actor electricity are just
electricity arc so select that one and
what I'm going to do for the beam is I
am going to rotate him 90 degrees on the
z axis and basically that is that so we
can compile and save that
now if
I were to go and put this block so if I
go back over here let me just
right-click and create a new folder and
this one is going to be interactive
elements so interactive elements folder
where we are going to put our
interactive elements if I go into the
blueprints and put the interactive block
and I'm going to put it over here
interactive elements and if I position
the first one is going to be at two
thousand eight hundred and six zero for
the Y and for the Z one one two five
there you go we are also going to
rescale it so over here click on the
lock icon for the scale and over here
the scale is going to be 1.5 there you
go
so compile that or save the current if I
hit the play button we can come close to
it and we can jump on it and all of that
stuff so that is totally fine but you
know nothing is happening because we
need to be able to drag it towards us
in order to move it over here so that we
can then jump from here to here to here
to here to here so you get the point so
let's go back in the BP interactive
block and here in the event grab the
first thing we are going to create a
couple of variables so click here we're
going to have one variable two three and
four variables the first one is going to
be the player reference so player re f
so reference to the player which is
going to be a type of our BP player ball
so a ball and there you go object
reference the second one is going to be
the move direction so move direction and
this is as you can assume a vector so we
are going to have a vector next we're
actually going to have one extra
variable so the next one is going to be
can be pushed and the third one is go
fourth one that is going to be can
detect player and last but not least
we're going to have the UI HUD reference
or UI HUD now these two are going to be
boolean as you can assume but the UI HUD
is going to be the game HUD so hot b.p
game HUD object reference compile and
save that now above
first I'm going to delete all of this
and above the begin play we are going to
create a custom event so we're here
we're going to say custom event and
we're going to call this one lock all
rotations and this will not allow the
rotations or it will not allow the game
object the actor to rotate so what's
gonna happen from here is we are going
to get the physics constraints and from
there we are going to drag a node and we
are going to say set angular swing one
limit and we are going to continue the
execution flow from there and motion
type is not going to be free but it's
going to be locked because we are not
going to be allowed to move from here we
are going to have our physics constraint
that we're going to say set angular
limit or swing limit two and this goes
over here but I am going to do something
like this and like this so that it is
more readable so over here for the
angular swing to limit it's also going
to be locked and last but not least we
are also going to move from here I'm
going to say set angular twist twist
limit here it is plug it in over here
but I'm also going to double click on
this to create another line or dot on
this node line so locked there you go so
this is going to be our lock all
rotations which is basically not going
to allow our node or actually our actor
to rotate and I'm going to call this one
lock all so lock all rotations there you
go compile and save that in a side of
our begin play we are going to first
delay so we're going to say delay over
here for one second so we are going to
delay for one second and the reason why
we need to delay is because next we are
going to get the player pawns so we are
going to right click over here and get
the player pawn
and from here I'm going to cast ubp
player ball or ball player however
however we called it so plug this in
over here and next from it we are going
to set the player our EF so here it is
our player reference so plug this in and
next we are going to set the UI HUD over
here now the HUD is going to be set from
the player hut so come on over here
actually we're going to get it get the
HUD reference and then we are going to
set it over here now this is exactly the
reason why we're delaying you can test
it out on your own I'm not going to do
that over here because I already tested
it so you can do that on your own but
I'm going to explain why we are delaying
over here because in side of our let me
just take a look at over here was it in
the player I think it's not in the
player but it's actually in the VP over
here inside of the HUD itself so when we
go in the event construct over here we
are getting the player and setting our
self to the reference inside of the
player variable HUD reference and this
HUD if you remember is being created in
the game mode in the begin play and over
here in the interactive block in the
begin play we're getting the reference
to the player to get the reference to
the HUD
so by delaying here one second we are
allowing all of this to be already
performed so we wait one second before
we do all of this over here which means
the UI HUD will be created then the UI
HUD will get a reference to the player
and it will add self to the reference of
the HUD reference inside of the players
so that we can actually get it from here
but you can test it out try to use it
without this delay and we'll see that
you will not have a reference date
because it will not get a chance to be
created before we try to get access to
it over here so next from here we are
going to lock all rotations all
rotations and now that we have
all rotations next we are going to get
the beam which is our particle system we
are going to simply deactivate it
because we don't want it to work before
we actually start interacting with it
now we can select all of this over here
the begin play and I can create a
comment I can say something like
initialize the cube so like this compile
and save that so moving forward next
select the detection trigger so make
sure that you select it this is really
important so first select the detection
trigger and from there right click and
then here in the search type on
component begin overlap there you go and
we want this one on a component begin
overlap in parenthesis detection trigger
so what's going to happen over here in
side of the on component begin overlap
is that we are going to try and cast so
cast to be P player ball and we are
going to cast the other actor meaning
basically the actor that we have
interacted with if that is true so we
have collided with the actor our ball
actor that is then we are going to go
from here and first get right click and
get the player controller and from the
player controller we are going to enable
the input and over here I'm going to
plug this in and not in the target over
here but the player controller there you
go the target itself but the player
controller is the one who is going to
you see pushes this actor on the stack
and input being handled by the player
controller next we are going to get our
UI HUD and from there we are going to
show interaction text so from here like
this we're going to plug it in show the
interaction text compile and save that
now I can copy all of this and we can
select the detection trigger again
because now we need to do the same thing
but the opposite so right click over
here and we are going to say on
component and
overlap and it's gonna be the same thing
as I said so we are going to try and
cast to the VP player ball the other
actor if it's true but here we're not
going to enable the input instead we're
going to disable input here it is
disabled the input and plug in the
player controller over here because well
now we don't want to interact and also
over here from the UI HUD we don't want
to show but hide the text so hide the
interaction text and we are going to
plug this in over here there you go so I
can move this something like this over
here and by the way I am going to select
these and I'm going to comment them and
group them in a comment and I'm going to
say here triggers or you know overlap
our how everyone I call triggers for
detecting collision with player compile
and save that now we can test this out
if I go back here in the example map hit
the play button when I come close to our
cube we know that it has a large
collider so if I come close you see II
to interact if I move away it goes away
so this is what we just just did a
moment ago again if we come close eetu
interact because if you go over here you
see this is that trigger this is the box
when we come close to it or inside of it
we will see this because this is what we
did over here this is that line of code
now of course this will not allow it
this is not enough for it to actually
allow us to move the cube towards the
ball so we need to program that as well
so let's go back inside of our
platformer or actually interactive block
and right here below our on component
begin overlap we are going to get Arctic
event back so what's gonna happen from
the TIC event well this is where the
magic is gonna happen this is where
we're going to pool our cube towards the
ball so first we are going to go from
event
to a gate now what is a gate well a gate
basically as you can see allows for
opening and closing a gate to control
the execution flow
so basically when we open this gate we
enter this gate but we need to open it
to be able to execute what's after the
gate so we need to open it and when we
close it so nothing is gonna happen so
basically this is how we control the
execution flow and in order to open the
gate we need to get our actions so which
is our input so input action action here
it is there you go input action action
which is basically this one over here or
input action interact you can also call
it interact like this and let me just go
back and see it will this change will
this change - will this change so right
click over here we can say interact and
there you go so input action interact
this is much better than input action
action so when we press the button and
we know that that button is e so when we
press the button we are going to take
the beam and we are first going to
activate it so make sure that the beam
is activated so over here
plug in the execution and from there for
after we activated the beam then we are
going to go and open the gate
now also when we release the button we
are going to deactivate the beam so when
we release the button we are going to
deactivate the beam and we are going to
go inside of the closed gate which means
when we open it so when we press the
button we open it and then it will work
when we release the button we close it
and nothing will happen after this exit
so also one thing that we're going to do
is over here create a custom event and
this custom event is going to be closed
interaction gate and it's simply going
to go over here to D
2-8 the beam so deactivate the beam and
then from there go and close the gate so
in these two cases when we release the
interact button which is the e button we
will close the beam or deactivate it and
close the gate and also when we call
this custom event close interaction gate
we will deactivate the beam and close
the gate only when we press the button
we will open the gate so what's gonna
happen when we open the gate
well first we are going to test if our
player is valid so get the player
reference and from here we are going to
test is valid with a question mark and
why we're testing that meaning do we
have the player inside of our game so if
we don't have the player so if we don't
have if it's not that valid we don't
have it we're going to say close
interaction gate because we don't have
the player so what is the point of doing
anything because you know if we don't
have the player we cannot interact so
close the interaction gate and also take
the UI Hut
so from here take the UI Hut and from
here hide the inter action text so this
also goes over here plug it in compile
and say that this is if the player is
not valid meaning we destroyed him if he
is valid we are going to go in a
sequence so sequence and a sequence is
basically an execution order if I hover
over see execute a series of pins in
order first this one will be executed
then this one and we if you have more
you see if you have more you can you
know execute them in order but they are
executed in the order 0 it's gonna be
first 1 then 1 then 2 then 3 then yada
yada yada so first what we are going to
do is go over here and we are going to
get the player reference so first we
need to get the player reference and
from here we are going to call the
energy damage and this goes over here
like this so I'm going to move it a
little bit up something like this
there you go move it a little bit over
here now the damage that the energy is
going to be 50 if you remember in our
player if I double-click it you will see
the energy damage the positive values
are equal damage negative values are
equal to heal because over here if we
have a positive number it is going to be
let's say 50 multiplied with the world
Delta seconds multiplied with 1 and then
we are going to subtract that from the
energy you see we're subtracting that
from the energy so we're saying the
positive value minus the energy and then
we're clamping that value between 0 and
100 but if we have a negative value and
I told you this is your assignment to
figure out how it works so let's go back
over here so here we are dealing damage
or actually subtracting from the energy
of the player next we are getting the
beam so over here and for the beam we
are going to say set beam source point
and the source point is going to be in
this case the player reference you are
going to get the actor location which is
the location of our player so the source
point for the beam is going to be the
players location but now the end point
or the target point so over here for the
beam I'm going to say set beam target
point basically where the beam starts
and where the beam ends so over here the
end is going to be from the mesh itself
and we are going to get the world
location like this and we're going to
plug it in over here so something like
this there you go compile and save that
so this is what's gonna happen first and
I think we need to do this all of this
little bit down
for obvious reasons to make it more
readable so in this execution this
sequence first we are going to do all of
this and this is self-explanatory I
don't think that we need to go into more
detail what this is then what we are
going to do is we are going to go into
compare float and over here you will see
if I hover over compare one float to
another and indicate if it's greater
less than or the same now I'm going to
double click over here so that I can
create it like this so who are we going
to compare well we're going to get the
player reference and from the player
reference I'm going to get the energy
and the energy is going to be the input
or the one that is going to be compared
and we are going to compare it with 0.5
so depending off if it's greater less
than or equal to we are going to do
certain things first things first if
it's equal to or less than 0.5 we are
going to close the interact or
interaction gate so we're going to close
the gate and we are going to take the UI
HUD and from here we are going to hide
the interaction text because if the
energy gets to the value which is equal
to 0.5 or lower than and I'm going to
click this here as well and I'm going to
move this over here and plug this in
over here so basically these two go so
these two execution pins go inside of
this one which go over here because
again if the value of the energy comes
to the value of 0.5 or less than 0.5
then we are not going to continue to
drag or pull that cube towards us
because we don't have any more energy to
do that however if it's greater than 0.5
then what we are going to do is we are
going to get the mesh and for the mesh
we are going to add force and this goes
over here but don't worry we still need
to do a few
it's not simply like this because we
need to add a force that will pull it
together and that force is going to be
we're going to get the player reference
and we're also going to get the mesh and
from the player reference we are going
to get the actor location so get the
location from our character and we can
move this a little bit down just like
that and this one over here for the mesh
we're going to get the world world
location there you go
and we are going to subtract them from
one another so we're going to say minus
vector so vector minus vector here you
go and we need to move this a little bit
further here so that we can have more
space maybe move these a little bit
backwards now for this pin I'm going to
right click and split the pin structure
because I want to get XY and z
separately because now I want to make a
vector so make vector and I want to plug
X and I want to plug Y so plug them in
and next from here we are going to
normalize this so normalize and after
that we're also going to get the mesh
over here from the mesh we are going to
get the mass and from the mass we are
going to multiply it with a float and
the float valve is going to be one
thousand and last but not least we still
need to move this a little bit over here
because now we need to multiply this
with a float plug this in over here and
plug this in over here
compile and save that so now we can
create a comment section from it tick to
pull the cube to the ball there you go
and compile and save that and for some
reason I you know I like to write these
capitals lowercase big case anyways it's
not important let's go and revise this
before we test it out again so that I
can make sure that everything is clear
so when we call the tick event we are
going to end
the gate the gate will open only when we
press the interact button and with it we
will activate the beam which is the
particle effect if we release the button
we will deactivate the beam and we will
close the gate and also when we call the
close interaction gate custom event we
will deactivate the beam and close the
gate
when the gate is closed this exit and
everything what's after it will not
execute so everything will not execute
if the gate is closed because the gate
allows us to control the workflow if the
gate is open then everything over here
will execute moving forward when we
execute what's after the gate we're
first testing if a player is valid or do
we have the player in the game if we
don't close the interaction gate and
hide the interaction text if we do have
the player he is valid first subtract
the energy from the player because he's
using the energy to pull the ball or the
cube and use the beam to set the source
point and the target point so that
actually it will look like this this is
our cube this is our ball so the beam
will be between them so it will be on
the cube and it will be on the ball
after that we are going to compare the
float for the energy if it's greater
than 0.5 we are going to first if it's
equal to or less than 0.5 close the
interaction gate hide the interaction
text because we don't have enough energy
to pull the cube if it's greater than
0.5 then we are going to use the player
reference and his location and the mesh
location we are going to subtract from
the player location the location of the
mesh we are going to create a vector
using the X and the y from that
calculation we are going to normalize
that vector and we're going to get the
mass and multiply it by 1000 now of
course these are arbitrary values like
this 1000 and so on and so forth you can
test it out you can like use 3000 you
can use a gazillion but you know I've
tested it out with 1000 and it works
well
so using that multiplying the mass with
the mesh and then multiplying these two
together adding that force will make it
move slow
we're River why am I using these
objectives but anyways this is or this
is the calculation for adding the force
so now if I go back over here if I hit
the play button if I come close to the
cube we will see the interact if I go
away
we don't see if I press E now nothing is
happening if I come close where it says
interact if I press E BAM you see it is
coming closer you see BAM it is coming
closer there you go now one thing that
we do have that is not working is the
following so over here I believe I've
missed something over here yeah new Otto
the target is actor component this is
not how to activate it's actually
activate not auto activates so this goes
over here and this goes over here and
this reset goes there compile and save
that so it's not auto activate excuse me
for this one so not how to activate its
activate for the bing and also make sure
this reset you see whether the
activation should happen even if should
after returns fall so basically just
reset the beam where it was so activate
will turn on the beam so let's try it
out now and for some reason I you know
selected how to activate I didn't even
notice that
so now if I move it you see there you go
so if I come close now over here and I'm
moving this cube now I can do this so
here there you go
and I can go over here but now we cannot
pass these without the other cube
actually we can but we will die yeah so
we need other cubes inside so let me
just quickly add those other cubes so
we're going to have interactive block to
you so let me just this interactive
block one copy and paste it the
interactive block to is going to be at
7,900
9 for them X Y is 0 Z is 3,000 0 8 1
there you go so it's gonna put it over
here as you can see and yeah we are
going to leave it like that so maybe
just over here there we go and copy and
paste it because we are going to have a
third one as well and this one is going
to be at X 13,000 1 3 9 minus 160 for
the Y and for the Z 4701 which is going
to put him over here because when he
when we go up we will need to drag this
bad boy down in order to be able to jump
up and finish the level so if I hit the
play button now and if I go over here
with the ball and I jump over here and I
come close over here come on let's move
this bad boys come on over here hope
look good good
there we go so now what we need to do is
pull this bad boy over here so the
lasers don't touch us there you go and
over here we will have the elevator
that's gonna pull us up
and when we go up then we will be able
to interact with the other cube so there
you go come on can I actually pull this
now I can you know the lasers cannot do
anything to us but yeah there you go so
anything if something is not clear
before we proceed please ask in the
comment below because the next step is
to actually click create the elevator
and wrap up our game so let us right
click over here blueprint class actor so
it inherits from the actor and it's
gonna be BP underscore elevate or la the
tour actually is it spelled like this
it's like this I have a shoe spelling so
don't judge me anyways going back over
here selecting the elevator top root
component we are going to filter for the
mesh
so actually static mesh here it is not
instant smash what the hell is this
static mesh here it is and we're going
to call it or elevator mesh Allah they
elevate or mesh I'm going to make this
the default route component now over
here for the static mesh we are going to
filter for the elevate or SM elevator
why am i spreading elevator with LEF e
it's le FA so there you go this is our
elevator now over here for the element
or the material for it it's gonna be the
stone material stone material here it is
stone mat and this is going to be our
elevator compile save that now we are
going to select it and we are going to
attach box
so over here box collision there you go
so this box collision I'm going to
simply call it trigger and we are going
to resize it of course now we are going
to set the Z position to 215 and the
extent over here the box extent 400 for
the X 400 for the Y and the Z can be 100
so there you go this is our box
collision and it will detect when well
the player comes close on it simple as
that now going here in the event graph
I'm going to delete everything over here
and I'm going to add a couple of
variables we are going to need 1 2 3 4 5
6 variables then I add 6 and we will add
them on the go so over here the first
one is going to be our UI HUD re f so
reference to the UI HUD the next one
click on it is going to be speed of plat
form the next one is going to be up
limit the next one is going to be the
down limit the next one is going to be
years
Vinc and last but not least the last
one's going to be moved up so the UI Hut
is our gamehud which is simple we did
this already
numerius of times speed of platform it's
going to be a float next our up limit is
also going to be a float our down limit
is also going to be a float and is
moving and move up are going to be
bullying's now by default the speed of
platform I don't know we can set it at 3
by default so we can compile and save
that up limit we are not going to touch
that or we can but we will see later
don't worry about that so basically you
can set it at three thousand six three
thousand four hundred and sixty five
this is the up limit and the down limit
you can set at two thousand four hundred
eighty five we will see what this is now
make sure that speed-up limit and down
limit are public variables because we
will want to edit them well we will want
to edit them on inside of our level
directly so anyways let's bring back the
begin play what is this
so event begin play here it is so in the
begin play we are going to delay the
same reason why we are delaying over
here in the interactive box interactive
block at the top so the same reason why
we are delaying over here the execution
we are delaying two seconds and what we
are going to do after that is that we
are going to cast ubp player ball now
who am i casting of course the player
pawn so get player pawn and plug this
bad boy in over here after that what I
need is to get the reference from the UI
HUD and the UI HUD is inside of the
players we are going to say get HUD here
it is and plug it in over here so now we
have the reference to the UI HUD we got
that from the player
now what we're going to do now select
the trigger so make sure the trigger is
selected and right click and we are
going to filter for on component begin
overlap same thing we are going to right
click and filter for on component and
overlap so on component actually we
didn't select the trigger so select it
right-click on component and overlap
there you go so when we when the overlap
begins when we detect collision we first
want to cast so cast ubp player ball so
casting to the ball the other actor
because we need to detect if we are
colliding with the ball if the ball is
on the elevator then what we are going
to do is we are going to get the player
controller get player controller there
you go and from here we are going to
enable the input here it is enable the
input and plug this in over here and
from there we are also going to get our
HUD reference and we are going to show
the interaction text show the
interaction text this is when the player
comes on when it's on the elevator over
here when the overlap ends however we
are going to again cast to VP player
ball and we are casting the other actor
we do need the player controller again
so copy and paste them over here and
from here we are going to disable the
input and plug in the player controller
now we are also going to get the UI HUD
copy and paste and this time we are
going to hide the interaction text so
hide it but we are also going to do one
more thing and that is over here we are
going to say is moving and we are going
to plug this in or we are going to say
that we are going to check the check box
so in the
that we are moving and over here are
going to say move up is false and we
will see in a second why we are doing it
like that so this is when we collide
with the player again this is all safe
explanatory all of this here I don't
have to explain all of this here when we
you know simply check if we collided
with the player this enable the input
and show the text that we need to
interact when we when the player goes
away from the elevator then if that is
true disable the input hide the text and
is moving is true and move up is false
which means we are going to move down
but over here I'm going to right click
and I'm going to say action interact so
when we press the interact button what's
gonna happen well when we press it we're
going to go inside of a branch and the
condition for that branch is going to be
our is moving and we're going to plug it
in over here if is moving is false so
meaning we're not moving we're going to
say set move up to be true so if we're
not moving move up is true and over here
set is moving to be equal to true there
you go
so only if is moving is not true meaning
we are not moving currently so we are
not moving then we are going to move up
and is moving is true which means now
inside of our tick so going back in the
event tick I mean we can test this out
now I mean tested we can we can show we
can just displayed how it looks like
because we cannot test it we cannot move
up and down so I can put the elevator
over here and I'm going to put it in the
interactive elements and the elevators
position X is going to be 10,000 660 the
Y position is going to be negative 190
the Z position is going to be 2 4 8 5
there you go which means here it is
there is the elevator and I can quickly
just test it out so we can go over here
we will wait a few moments for me to
test it out but I mean it is going to
work so interact there you go
come on moving this cube over here we we
we there you go jumpy jumpy jumpy
come on move this bad boy over here
there you go okay so now we are on the
elevator if we jump on him there you go
e to interact nothing is gonna happen if
we interact right now because if we
press E I mean we pressed E and and is
moving is now true and move up is true
but we're not doing anything which means
we need to do it over here so we need to
go inside of our tick inside of the
elevator and what's gonna happen over
here we are gonna go in a branch and
that branch is going to be controlled by
is moving so going over here if is
moving if that is true we are gonna go
inside of another branch and for that
branch we're gonna use move up so get
the move up and what's gonna happen over
here well let's go first if it's true if
we should move up we are gonna go inside
of a branch and what I need to do is
move this a little bit down so that we
can see it more clearly so we are gonna
go in the branch and the condition for
this branch is going to be you
double-click it and like this so the
condition for this branch as I said is
going to be we're going to get the actor
location so get actor location and we're
going to split the pin structure and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make a vector make vector and the value
X and the value I are going to go here
but the value Z we are going to add to
it plus float and the float that we are
going to add and let me just remove this
this goes over here like this the value
that I'm going to add to the Z value is
going to be the speed of the platform
I'm going to plug in the speed of the
platform what we need to do to test this
out is take the speed or this
calculation over here the Z value plus
the speed of the platform and we need to
compare if that is greater than or equal
to so if it's greater greater than or
equal to up limit so we have our up
limit and I'm going to plug it in over
here and that goes inside of this branch
why are we using the up limit because we
are going upwards if move up is true we
are not going to allow our Z position to
be above the up limit so if it's greater
than or equal to the upper limit so if
that is true then we're going to say set
is moving to be equal to false and over
here we're going to say set actor
location not world offset set actor
location here it is this goes over here
is moving is now false and over here if
this is false this goes directly over
here but let me just do it like this so
that we can clearly see it what is
happening something like this and from
here this goes over here of course for
the Z this needs to go over here so this
is what we are essentially doing now
what is this what the hell dude don't
cry man
do not cry because I'm gonna show you
what it is in the TIC event if we are
moving if it's true then we are going to
test if we should move up so we are
moving but are we moving up or down if
move up is true then we are going to get
the current location of the player and
create a vector out of it
x and the y are going to stay the same
but for the z axis because we are moving
it up and we're going to use the z axis
for that so we are going to add to the z
axis the speed of platform if that new
value is greater or equal to the up
limit if that is true stop moving if
it's false then go here into the set
actor location and set the
new location by using the new Z position
that we gained from adding to the
current value of Z the speed of the
platform this is what we are doing and
as you can assume if it's false if
move-up is false that means we're going
to do the opposite so we are gonna go
here in another branch but we are going
to do the opposite instead of going up
we are gonna go down so we are going to
right-click and I am going to get the
actor location I am going to split the
pin structure and this can go over here
and I'm also going to make a vector so
right click make vector and again x and
y are gonna stay the same the z axis
over here so I'm going to move this over
here the value of the Z I'm going to
subtract from it a float and the value
that I'm going to subtract is going to
be the speed of platform now if this
value is less than or equal to because
now we are going downwards so if this
value is less than or equal to the down
limit and this goes over here BAM and I
can move this probably over here like
this the down limit and it's pretty
clear so we're testing if the current
value of over here is less than or equal
to the down limit now if that is true
again set is moving to false and after
that set actor location and the location
is going to be set by the returning
value over here I'm also going to plug
this in over here and if it's false
again so if it's false this still goes
over here click it like this click it
like this there you go so wallah this is
what we are doing compile and save that
so using the tick event and based on if
we are moving up or down we are going to
move the elevator let us test that
so if I hit the play button and if I go
back over here and interact with this of
course we don't have to do it right now
so come on over here there you go
then Bam Bam Bam Bam
there you go jumpy jumpy jumpy come on
bad boy fall down there you go
so now pay attention if I come to the
elevator if I hit the e button you see
he is going up as soon as I remove away
from him the elevator goes down now how
the elevator knows that it should go up
to the point over here if I select the
elevator it goes up to the point three
six four and it goes down to two four
eight five if you pay attention the down
limit is the current Z position of the
elevator you see the down limit over
here that I'm pointing with the arrow is
the current position of the Z if we move
up it will go up to the value three four
six five so basically what I did is I
you know move the elevator like this and
saw up to where I want to move the
elevator and then I set the maximum
position or the up limit and the down
limit this is how I calculated the up
limit and down limit that's why I said
over here we can leave it to be zero by
default or we can leave it or we can
then you know you can set the value
because I knew the value because I
already prepared the project but we can
set them at zero and when you position
the elevator in the game and from there
you can then use that use the values of
the position to you actually to actually
set that
so again if it's not clear if something
is not clear when it comes to this over
here just let me know in the comment
below so that I can explain it so let's
does the game out one more time so when
I hit the play button we have the ball
we can move if we fall down over here we
are losing health as you can see we can
interact with the cube so I can just
move it like this come on Cuba Cuba QB
there you go and jump jump jump jumps
like a spider-man go over here if I fall
down we know what's going to happen
but let's move the cube and not fall
down and actually move the cube like
this over here towards us Hey
so yeah and now the laser cannot do
anything for us so let's go over here
interact with the elevator and we can go
up now how can we interact with this
cube well of course we need to jump and
move it like this there you go
so interact like this jump and move it
and now we can jump over here on top and
there we go now basically as I said and
you see over here we have e to interact
from the cube so that the collider of
the cube is this large so it can catch
us but anyways you can fix that that's
not important also over here on the top
you can add a flag or whatever you want
to do you can the ending of the game is
up to you so you can add a flag like
level finish as you already saw and I
showed you that in the beginning you can
move these cubes to these rocks actually
to create a different level so this
serves like a template that you can
build upon you can add expanded and so
on and so forth so the ending of this
game is up to you you can practice add
new features and probably share that in
the comment below with us as we can see
anyways thank you for watching till the
end of this tutorial
it was very nice it was very
entertaining creating yet hopefully it
was nice for you to watch it I don't
know I mean until next video
if you like this video make sure that
you like share comment subscribe so that
you know that will help the algorithm
and other people will see it yeah if you
like what you see I have plenty more of
this in my ultimate game Development
Academy a link will be in the
description below
until then again thank you for watching
I will see you guys in the next video